un aller sans pour les caraïbes et un
grand air de vacances avant l'heure
autour du château de plaisir pour la 11e
édition du festival escales d'ailleurs
l'ambiance et c'est tout le temps coule
voilà c'est festif cscad d'ailleurs et
je viens d'ailleurs et voilà
dans l'espace tous ces pays qu il ya un
baby nous sommes contents de vous
accueillir à plaisir pour nous amuser et
faire la fête ensemble l'ocp là c'est
très sympa le thème sur les pirates bas
c'est très intéressant pour les enfants
sinon maya des jeux de tous les âges on
peut se restaurer on a passé une très
bonne journée des animations avec la
compagnie des pirates bretons et leur
navire baptisé l'improbable des parcours
sportifs et d' aventure comme ce jeu de
corps mexicaine
mais aussi la construction d'un mini
village de maison à base de torchis un
mélange d'argile et de paille un procédé
ancestral écologique les maisons comme
ça se faisait aussi là-bas dans le temps
c'était une technique est utilisée
dans des pays comme ça notamment des
pays chauds parce que les maisons en
torchis sa garde la fraîcheur on trouve
les torchis dans la terre là ici donc on
n'a pas en aller le chercher je saison
et tout est naturel
des dégustations tout au long de la
journée car la culture créole c'est
aussi sa gastronomie morue salée banane
plantain brochettes de boeuf mais aussi
pas de manioc entouré de feuilles
écrites à l'étuvée
diversité des cultures et des gens
artistique avec ce spectacle
chorégraphique aux influences mêlées
la base en fait c'est la danse africaine
congolaise c'est par là que j'ai
commencé avant j'ai fait aussi un petit
peu de modern'jazz et j'ai vraiment eu
envie de mixer un petit peu les deux
parce que j'avais vu des ballets georges
monboye york est très connue en danseur
à faux tampon est en fait j'étais un
petit peu inspiré par tout ça et je me
disais pas tous ces mélanges là que ces
métissages de danses différentes
finalement c'est très enrichissant
braga tonnes zouk musiques
traditionnelles et folkloriques tous les
styles étaient représentés
la fanfare ben dites a entraîné les
plaisirs aux au plein coeur de cuba
saint domingue porto rico la sas et
rythme festif et coloré
une ambiance carnavalesque et
extravagante illustré par la démesure de
ses marionnettes géantes avec à leurs
commandes et pilotes experts
comme chaque année près de dix mille
personnes avaient réservé leurs billets